this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
gentlemen thank you for joining us today
I'm going to turn the discussion over to
Professor shock say who will get us
started with an overview of the energy
research that's happening here at
Stanford University within the
Department of Chemical Engineering some
of the multidisciplinary groups within
the School of Engineering and the
interdisciplinary groups within the
School of Engineering school of Earth
Sciences and the like Michele thank you
yes as Michelle said what I'd like to do
is start the discussion by talking about
the energy activities on campus
particularly the research activities and
more specifically the spectrum of those
activities which you see up in the upper
left-hand corner of this slide actually
as given to us by lynn or the director
of GCF who's also was making a
presentation at the slack science policy
committee and what you see there is a
spectrum of activities all the way from
the fundamental basic science aspects of
energy research to the policy regulation
and law on the top is the are the sub
headings for the spectrum and on the
bottom are actually centers associated
at Stanford with research activities the
bottom line of this slide is supposed to
indicate that we are heavy on the policy
and regulation side and less heavy on
the basic science side and over the last
I would say five to ten years that's
changing rapidly where the basic science
side the basic molecular transformations
that are associated with energy research
are actually growing dramatically at
Stanford and that's part of the reason
for this webinar to actually talk about
molecular transformations that are
associated with energy and the research
is going on at Stanford and how that can
become available to everybody in the
community from an education point of
view and outside the community one of
the big aspects of the basic science
side is this new Sun cat that is
sustainable energy through catalysis
Center it's a center that lives jointly
with slack and Chemical Engineering as
you see on the logo on the right
and this Center is focused on the
molecular transformations and basic
science part of energy and this is a
very new development a few years old but
it's already growing and a lot of the
educational activities that are
associated with molecular
transformations essentially originate in
some cap so the reason that this
partnership naturally evolved that is
the Sun Katz Center which is located at
SLAC and the chemical engineering
department is because more than half of
the faculty in chemical engineering are
actually engaged in energy research
every year we have more than half of our
undergraduates come to us and say they
want to do undergraduate research and
energy and the focus of that research in
the chemical engineer partner is on
molecular transformation on the right is
actually suncast logo and not
surprisingly the Sun plays a large role
in that logo that's because many if not
all of renewable energy alternative
energy sources are actually a means of
harvesting the sun's energy and so what
you see there is the Sun up in the upper
left hand corner and it being harvested
through a number of efficient and
renewable processes so it's this Center
and this collaboration that I want to
focus on today when I talk about
molecular transformations of energy also
within the chemical engineering faculty
there are many many other centers some
associated with policy some associated
with the with the basic science and
chemical engineering again plays a
leadership role in many if not all of
those centers including some of the
centers that I'm sure some of you are
familiar with for listening these the
people that are associated with these
centers include Tom hare Emil who's here
today Shannon bow Jaden cosa yen's
Northcott Stacey bent and a variety of
other faculty that will touch upon as we
go along
now let's talk a little bit about the
role that molecular transformations play
in energy research and why our feeling
is that this is really where the
technology is going if there are going
to be large breakthroughs in energy
research in the future they're going to
be at the molecular level or the nano
scale and I've indicated that in perhaps
the simplest situation here on this
slide you can harvest the sun's energy
in a variety of ways the simplest
situation is absorption by a bandgap
material in which you create an electron
and a hole and then the an efficient way
to keep that energy if you will is to
produce a fuel with it these are called
solar fuels and what I'm showing here is
the production of hydrogen from the
electron that results from the splitting
as a result of the sun's rays and so
there are a number of ways to engineer
this process that is the process in the
upper right-hand corner you can either
enter engineer the absorption you can
engineer the hydrogen evolution catalyst
which ultimately causes the combination
of H ions into hydrogen or you can
engineer the oxygen evolution catalyst
which in this particular case is over on
the left hand side so catalysis which is
the study of lowering energy barriers so
such reactions take place it's a
critical plays a critical role in energy
on renewable energy and and the
challenge is we need a fishing catalyst
stable catalyst and abundant catalysts
and that usually means catalyst made
from earth abundant elements and then
finally we need design rules and
understanding for those catalysts and
that's again design rules at the
molecular or nano scale so for example
here's some research from Tom Mara mios
group who's going to talk a little bit
later about the development of one of
these earth-abundant catalysts that is
in this case molybdenum sulfide or
molybdenite in its natural state in the
ground and the concept here is to
engineer activity that is at
Vivat e for the h ER or the hydrogen
combination reaction that we showed on
the previous slide what you need to do
it turns that is to create more edge
States edge States or feature state in
the molybdenum actually a hot more
highly active and so as you see there's
a variety of textured molybdenum
sulfides here that are used correct for
hydrogen catalysts and those have been
engineered by Tom all the way from
nanowires to as you see fibrous
materials molybdenum sulfide isn't the
most active catalyst for that process it
turns out precious metals are but
precious minerals are expensive and this
activity is quite high for a material
that's earth abundant so this is just an
example of engineering on molecular
transformation that has direct
application to energy application as I
said you could also energy engineer the
absorption and so here's an example
actually from Stacy Benz group with in
chemical engineering where we're
engineering the absorption of energy by
controlling the solar cell in this
particular case quantum dots so we're
engineering the quantum dot this is a
quantum dot that's created by cadmium
sulfide that is distributed in a porous
tio2 and the idea is to layer the
cadmium sulphide using the atomic layer
deposition process and if you do that
you control the bandgap of the
absorption and then you control the
spectrum of the absorb light so you see
on the right hand side different Ald
cycles that is different sizes if you
will of the quantum dots have different
spectrums of absorption and so this is
one of the aspects that you can engineer
again at the molecular level because
you're doing atomic layer deposition to
create the solar cell which absorbs the
light and creates the ion electron pair
that we talked about in a previous slide
now the inverse of electrolysis is a
fuel cell we talked about making solar
fuels well a very efficient way of
then using those fuels and one of the
examples of those fuels is hydrogen is
through fuel cell operation and for
those of you who don't know fuel cell
essentially is the splitting of a fuel
into an ionic species and then
harvesting the electrons and the
electrons then produce a current and do
work in this particular case creating
light so this is a way an
electrochemical way of using the fuel
that you've created from the solar
process that I talked about earlier
again there's molecular engineering
going on because the anode at the anode
you have the splitting reaction of the
hydrogen in this particular case so we
can act as a catalyst
you have the electrolyte which controls
the transport of the ions through the
cathode side and then you have a
recombination reaction going on at the
cathode side to create the waste in this
particular case the water so this is a
very efficient process that can be
engineered molecularly at both the anode
to cathode and the electrolyte side now
modern applications actually would want
you to have the production of the solar
fuel and the use of that fuel in the
same material the same object this means
that it must operate in the upper left
hand corner in electrolysis mode meaning
you split the water and create the
hydrogen and then on the right hand side
in the fuel cell mode where you take the
h2 which is now the the fuel and return
it back to h2o using creating useful
work in this particular case creating
current it's actually a real challenge
to accomplish this because now the
electrolyte the membrane that sits
between the anode and the cathode
actually must be able to operate in both
modes in in both electrolysis mode and
fuel cell mode that means it must be
able to transport different species into
different modes and that again could be
engineered at the molecular level and
it's a soft materials problem and
there's a modified poly sulfone which is
down in the lower right hand
order a novel polymer membrane design
that's being developed at Stanford in
order to operate in both modes and have
a single device do it electrolysis and
fuel cells so again there's a mullet
there's a lot of molecular engineering
that goes on in the electrolyte which in
this particular case is a modified poly
cellphone so not all inorganic materials
are essentially the way to use these
solar fuels one of the fascinating
things is to engineer life in order to
do these things for you
again that's harvesting the sun's energy
but it's usually associated with another
fuel let's say a biomass you now
genetically engineer a bacteria
indicated in red here the genome is on
the left to the enzyme that results from
that genome is in the middle and then
the enzymatic pathway is on the right
the idea is to engineer the bacteria so
that it produces interesting fuels from
the raw materials on the left those are
called biofuels so if you're going to
understand energy in the modern age you
also better understand something about
biology particularly about bioenergy
systems and the genetic engineering of
organisms in order to produce
interesting and important fuels so the
chemical engineering department is
associated with dealing with all of
these things and so if you bring
together a set of experts from chemical
engineering they'll be able to tell you
about all aspects of this because our
themes within the department are the
chemistry of life associated with
biology the chemistry of energy
associated with many different elements
and then the chemistry of the
environment primarily associated with
sustainability so what we've done is
actually take people a subset of the
experts from Chemical Engineering
together to form this what we call the
meat program molecular and engineering
of energy technologies and to make the
education available not just to people
on Stanford but to people off campus
including all the aspects of molecular
engineering that I talked about in the
previous slide and so that's one of the
purposes today to make you
arise yourself with the meat program and
what the educational opportunities are
with
much Eric's sharing this information
with us I'm going to go ahead and move
the conversation over to Professor Tom
Hart Emil so he can go ahead and discuss
the fuels from sunlight Thanks
great thank you very much Michelle so
what I'll be talking about is making
fuels from sunlight and like to start by
asking a question of why would you want
to make fuels from sunlight and maybe we
can formulate that question a slightly
different way
we know that solar energy is fantastic
everyone is a big fan of photovoltaics
it's a great way to get a renewable
energy resource to provide electricity
for our homes and businesses and
potentially even cars and cellphones and
things wind power is also wonderful but
there are really two big problems or
several big problems actually in
bringing these technologies out to
market especially at a large scale one
of those big problems turns out to be
storing that electricity because we want
to use electricity 365 days a year at 24
hours a day but of course these
resources come and go as they please so
the real question is how are we going to
store that electricity and there is in
fact a way to do it already we can take
these renewable technologies and
basically feed them into the electricity
grid as we know it and when the sun is
shining or the wind is blowing we can be
consuming those renewable electricity
but then whenever the Sun Goes Down or
the wind stops blowing then we have to
use fossil fuels which is where we get
80 percent of our energy and by burning
things like coal or natural gas we can
provide that electricity in times of
need so one question I like for you to
think about is what percentage of all
the electricity is moving through the
grid what percentage what's the highest
percentage that you could be feeding
intermittent renewable electricity and
still have a stable grid that meets
everyone's demand what do you think it
is do you think it's 2% of the grid
capacity do you think it's 30% of the
grid capacity I think it's 80% of the
grid capacity well the answer is it's
20% and 20% turns out to be a pretty
small number when you think about it I
mean it's wonderful if we can have 20%
of all our electricity coming from
renewables I'd be tremendous but then
80% is still coming basically from
fossil fuels so we could put the dent
into the energy problem but at the end
of the day we need to find a good way to
store renewable
electricity and that's what the context
of what I like to share with you is why
we'd want to make fuels now there are
many different ways that you could
potentially be making fuels from
sunlight and in fact there's many
different ways you could be storing
electricity but what I have to show you
here on this particular slide is showing
you a number of different energy storage
modes that we can use already today we
can use pumped hydro which basically
mean you you use that renewable
electricity to pump water up a hill and
then let it flow back downhill to get
the energy out there are capacitors
there are batteries you can use
compressed air where again use that
renewable electricity to compress air
and then use that pressure to give you
electricity through a turbine on the on
the way back out but this is on this
particular plot where we're showing
volumetric energy density in mega joules
per liter versus mass energy density in
mega joules per kilogram you can see
that compared to these very conventional
technologies that we already use today
there is just really nothing to compete
with the chemical energy of molecular
bonds we're talking about conventional
fuels like diesel like gasoline like
natural gas propane ethanol you can see
that the energy stored in chemical bonds
is absolutely magnificent compared to
the energy stored and paid the
lithium-ion battery that's in your
pocket right now in your cell phone or
in capacitors or in pumped hydro so the
real question is you know so well this
slide really shows why we definitely use
fossil fuels because they really are a
fantastic form of of of energy storage
however the big problems are coming from
fossil resources so the question I'd
like to pose to you is well is there a
way to take advantage of all the
wonderfulness that are these chemical
fuels but without the fossil resource so
can we go from say fossil fuels instead
to solar fuels and produce them using
solar energy instead so let's think of a
way that we might do that so here's a
typical way an engineer would think
about the problem you basically draw a
black box and you say I'm going to feed
something in and get something out of it
so what might we feed in imagine feeding
in water feeding in carbon dioxide these
are obviously extremely abundant
molecules everybody all of us we're all
breathing these molecules right now and
imagine shining some sunlight onto that
black box and when you shine that
sunlight you provide some energy which
is going to allow for some chemical
transformations we can start moving and
rearranging some of these the
adam's around so what our output streams
we can have oxygen as one of our output
streams which is a useful molecule of
course but take a look at all the
different things that we could possibly
make when you feed it into this black
box we could be feeding in things or
getting an output of say alcohols which
are could be certainly used as fuels we
could get some gaseous hydrocarbons as
you see here with methane and ethylene
we could be making liquid hydrocarbons
which are the conventional fuels that we
put inside our cars and trucks and no
matter how you rearrange the bond
anything that you'd be making here could
be either you could actually be used
directly as a fuel I'd like to point out
that all of these molecules that you see
here have mass energy densities that are
within a factor of four of that of
gasoline so they could be actually using
the standard internal combustion engine
to get the energy back out a second
option is actually used these molecules
as chemical precursors to then make
whatever it is that you're after so for
instance if you made carbon monoxide and
hydrogen you could feed those into a
fischer tropsch plant and make diesel
and gasoline this is here today
technology that is already operating at
scale around the globe so the point is
what we've done with this is we've come
up with the process where you can shine
light and have a feed of just water and
carbon dioxide and make pretty much any
molecule that you'd want to use as a
fuel or molecules that you'd want to use
to feed into the chemical industry to
make the things that we use every day
like the high-density polyethylene that
goes into making milk jugs so the
question is what is inside that black
box there's many different possibilities
and what we're working on in my
laboratory is we're trying to figure out
electrochemical ways of doing these
chemical transformations and we're
interested in electrochemical
technologies because we need to say wind
and solar technology are very good at
producing these renewable electrons this
is a way that we can just feed these
electrons into such a process where you
can again grab that carbon dioxide and
use the energy here the uphill energy
that we need so that we can start
converting it back into a fuel which you
can then burn in your car the co2 goes
back into the atmosphere but then you
just recapture it and then recycle it
through renewable energy to complete
this cycle which is a net zero emission
of co2 so in this particular case we've
got two separate devices that do the
process or you can imagine more advanced
modes where you have an all-in-one
device where a device like this is
basically it looks like a photovoltaic
immersed underwater and when you when
you shine light on to the semiconductor
you excite electrons and holes just like
you would in a photovoltaic but then you
can actually do the chemical
transformations with water or co2 to
make the different products that we've
already talked about so let's talk about
how we start attacking this problem
either what you go with these are these
options I showed you on the previous
slide it's really all about moving atoms
around moving molecules around
rearranging bonds and so these are the
three reactions that we're really
focusing on quite a bit in our
laboratory you're making you take
protons and electrons you make hydrogen
or you can stick protons and electrons
on a carbon dioxide to make fuels and
chemicals and of course both of these
reactions need protons and electrons
where you're going to get them from you
can get them from a nice inexpensive
abundant resource being water so if you
oxidize water - OH - you release the
protons and electrons that you can use
for this process here if you read all
these reactions left to right that would
be the fuel production reaction that
requires energy input but of course once
you've made these molecules you want to
get the most energy back out of them and
so we're going to try to drive these
reactions right to left we need to
develop catalysts there as well and that
would be the fuel consumption mode and
the way I want you to look at these
reactions is that the fuel production
mode is energy in the fuel consumption
mode is energy out and so that if we
want to use chemicals as a means of
storing renewable electricity weather
comes from wind or solar we basically
want to get as much out as we can and
put as little in as we can and if you
divide those two numbers that gives you
a sense of the round trip efficiency of
storing electrochemical restoring
intermittent renewable energy in the
form of chemical bonds so as I've
already mentioned it's really all about
catalysis here is a necessary but
insufficient condition for something
like this to work on a large scale is
you need good catalysts that are able to
rearrange these bonds as we would like
and so this is the research approach a
methodology that we take within our
group to do that we basically design
materials we hypothesize what are
interesting materials to drive these
reactions what would be good surface
structures what would be good
stoichiometry and we get this
inspiration from a lot of places we do
some of our own theory to help guide us
we also collaborate with people like
Jen's Norco who's a dedicated
theoretician to to really guide
experimentalist in terms of materials
design and then we do a lot of synthesis
in our laboratory really focusing on
nano Mitch
because when you make things like
nanoparticles or nano wires or nano
porous materials these types of
materials will exhibit properties both
at the surface and at the bulk that are
different from what they would
conventionally be as a large particle
and then once we make these types of
materials we do a lot of microscopy and
spectroscopy because at the end of the
day what drives these chemical
transformations are these are all atomic
scale events molecular scale events so
we need to have atomically resolved
images like this one these are atoms
that you're looking at of a gold
nanoparticle catalyst we need to see how
those things are arranged at the surface
we also need to do spectroscopy where we
measure the electronic band structure we
literally look and see what are the
energies of the electrons in this
material because it's the electrons that
are really participating in the reaction
whether you're going backwards or
forwards and so once we've synthesized
and understand our material through and
through we can do our our catalyst
evaluation which tells us what works in
terms of activity selectivity and
stability we can take that information
and feed it right back into materials
designed to develop the next generation
system so at this stage with the last
couple minutes I just like to show you a
couple of examples on some of how we
adopt this methodology in developing
catalysts for hydrogen and for oxygen
reduction as well as for co2 reduction
and there's not enough time to go
through all the details if you're
interested in the details I would
certainly encourage you to look at some
of the references that we've published
recently in this area but here's one
case of looking at some core shell moly
oxide moly sulfide nanowires that we've
developed for hydrogen evolution
catalysis and the point I'd like to make
here is Eric alluded to earlier if you
look at this plot basically what this is
ranking a whole bunch of different
catalysts and where you really want to
be on this plot is down in this corner
where not surprisingly the precious
metals are the best but there are big
questions as whether precious metals
could ever scale in terms of energy
because we demand so much energy on this
planet 17 terawatts and climbing it's
not clear that precious metals could
even satisfy all our needs by mining
them at the rates that we would require
which of course would would hike up the
price to a point where it's probably not
going to be cost competitive versus
fossil fuels so in this case we're
trying to develop non-precious metal
catalysts that are scalable and here's
the moly sulfide which is not quite as
good but it is certainly better than a
lot of the other non precious metals out
there and in this particular design we
grew these nanowires where
are we actually we grew these nanowires
with a core shell structure 2d couple
two different important processes to do
electrochemistry and electric Attalla
--ss you need to be able to move
electrons up and down these wires but
you also need a good catalyst surface
and so it turns out that by making a
core that consisted of moly trioxide
which is very good at conducting
electrons and then put a shell of just a
couple of nanometers of MOS to which is
a good catalyst we were able to get
extremely active and stable hydrogen
evolution catalysis that could actually
operate in sulfuric acid for years and
years based on our accelerated
durability testing now the one thing
with this moly sulfide is that all the
action turns out to be happening at
these edge sites and there's not if you
take a look there's really not a lot of
edge sites around for these core shell
nano wires the way the moly sulfide
grows so another project that we've been
working on is how do you expose more
edge sites on the Molly sulfide so we've
come up with these nano porous
structures and as you can see by
basically having a really tight radius
of curvature the Molly sulphide has no
choice but to basically expose more of
these edge sites you can see the TEM
images here where we have porosities on
the order of about four nanometers
diameter and at the end of the day when
we take a look at the data we're
comparing this data is with this nano
porous material versus this data for the
core shell nano wires I showed you on
the previous slide basically any way you
cut it at any potential that you might
operate you're going to get one order of
magnitude ten times as much current
density out so these are these kettles
are ten times as good because we were
able to expose more of these edge sites
we've also adopted some of these
approaches in making fuel cell catalyst
so the conventional fuel cell catalyst
consists of platinum nanoparticles and
so by making nano porous designs of
platinum although they don't have just
they don't have quite as much surface
areas the nanoparticles they turn out to
be more active per site than the
nanoparticles and so if you look at this
bar graph where we do repeated
durability testing 10,000 cyclic
voltammogram switch Simplot stimulates 2
to 3 years of fuel cell operation you'll
see that in red this nano porous
material is not only better than the
conventional nanoparticles used but it's
also much more stable after this
accelerated durability testing wears you
can see the nanoparticles basically lose
activity over time because these
nanoparticles are not very stable they
will will Center together they'll clump
up and or the
detach from a surface never to be seen
or heard from again whereas the
contiguous thin film of a nano porous
material is much more inherently stable
and then finally I'd like to just point
out some of the work that we've been
doing in terms of carbon dioxide
conversion of fuels and chemicals which
really started with electro chemical
engineering of a reactor where we could
do this chemistry and measure products
simultaneously both gaseous and liquid
products of reaction and to make a long
story short on a copper surface if you
had looked back in literature the past
forty years of research in this area on
copper if you looked at every product
ever produced by any laboratory anywhere
around the earth there would have been a
grand total of ten different products
observed in our electrochemical reactor
based on our new methods that we've
adopted in one set of experiments we saw
all ten of those that everyone had ever
seen in the history of this field plus
six more that no no one had ever
reported on and so not only did we see
them we were able to quantify and you
can see all the products being made here
these are really wonderful products we
have carbon C one product C two product
C three products we've got hydrocarbons
we've got alcohols we've got carboxylic
acids ketones aldehydes some of these by
the way are in the global top 50 of
chemicals produced like ethylene glycol
for instance when you're in the global
top 50 that means you're making billions
we already currently today are making
billions of kilograms per year of these
products and if you do the math with
seven billion people in the face of the
earth that means that every man woman
and child on the face of the globe is
responsible for one kilogram per year of
some of these molecules being produced
so the question is can we produce those
molecules instead of from a fossil
resource can we make them from a
renewable resource this reactor is
something like this couple to renewable
energy could in fact do that but where
we're at scientifically today we're not
ready I think to commercialize this type
of process what we need to do is
understand what makes these catalysts
work and why does copper make all these
broad ranges of different types of
products so we've quantified how we're
in the potential scale they do it how
much current do we get and that allows
us to actually construct reaction
networks and do some mechanistic
analysis and this is basically providing
the insight that we need to develop
better catalysts in this field so with
that I'll just conclude by saying thank
you to my team for doing all the work
that I just presented to you today and
thanks also to the US Department of
Energy and the National Science
Foundation and the global climate energy
project or sponsoring this research I'll
turn it back to you Michelle thank you
thanks very much time I appreciate you
as you sharing this research with us and
now I'd like to turn it over to Ricardo
Levy who is going to talk about some of
the entrepreneurial challenges around
these energy industries and the
science-based industries Ricardo Thank
You Michelle first I'd like to thank Tom
and Eric I think that was fascinating
and it's been a long time since I was a
student that loves to become a student
again but more to the point I've spent
three decades building businesses in
technology areas many in the energy area
and there's a lot of stuff here that can
be can be developed further we're going
to switch gears now somewhat from the
previous conversation and we're going to
move into the the subject of teams
especially in our deep energy related
topics which take longer term to develop
and definitely our multidisciplinary the
issue of teams becomes essential so what
I'm going to talk a little bit is about
teams team leadership which here at
Stanford we feel is maybe not as
important as the innovation and the
invention but in the at the end of the
day if we want to take these commercial
the teams have to be effective so I'm
going to be talking about two topics
related to team leadership so I'm going
to talk about a couple of roles of the
intra entrepreneur key roles of the of
the intra entrepreneurial leader and the
first one I'm going to talk about is
maybe a little unusual and I see the
leader as being a risk adjuster so
obviously as many of our audience who
are deeply involved in commercial
enterprises know teams are really at the
heart of the innovative effort and as we
know the best the best teams have a
spectrum of skills and expertise and
each every team leader knows
that there is going to be a variety of
capabilities in in a team which kind of
make up for the richness of the team and
the effectiveness the one thing most of
us don't pay that much attention to is
that a team will have a spectrum also of
risk attitudes and risk aptitudes
different members of our team have if
you will risk different risk appetites
for example and this goes back to my own
experience a scientist will be very very
comfortable with pushing the boundaries
of technical know-how so the comfort
zone of the scientist is in the
technical uncertainty but you bring the
science and scientists into an
environment where there could be major
financial uncertainty which is the case
when you're an entrepreneur and you
start a company and their comfort zone
is very different
I have many cases in my in my experience
and in my business life where I know
specific individuals who were fearless
as they entered the unknown and push the
limits on the technology side but when
we turn the discussion on what's the
runway of the company and how much cash
we have left there was an enormous
degree of if you will fear and but the
fact is that you need to handle both in
order to be successful both the
technology uncertainty and the financial
uncertainty so the key role then of the
leader in my way of looking at it is to
absorb uncertainty to absorb that
difficulty that our team members may
have in coping with some of the issues
that may be outside of their particular
domain or even experience level and we
do that in order to
leave the team members to do what they
are best designed to do and at the end
of the day it all comes down to trust
and in fact I have a very simple minded
way of looking at it now it's simple
minded but it served me well over the
years both as a leader of a company but
also now lately as a board member to
understand the burden that CEOs carry
and the way I am envisioned I envisioned
it is every time you attract somebody to
your team to become part of your journey
you are really entering a relationship
and I am vision it as you receive a
trust packet and it is a real eye to eye
contact it's a deep contact and the
result is that you create a covenant
between the two of you as the leader
puts the trust packet in his backpack
now this may sound funny as a symbolism
but I tell you so often as I am in
meetings and I watch leaders of young
new companies handle some of the issues
I can personally feel how their backpack
is getting filled with all the issues
they have to go to now the challenge of
course is that the backpack is heavy as
more and more responsibility is taken
upon oneself and it is a very lonely
journey for the leader which really
raises this whole range of interesting
questions of how does a leader cope with
the increasing responsibilities and the
loneliness that comes with in effect
being at the top in particular when
you're dealing with a new venture either
within a larger organization or
are in a private company and it's a it's
a complex type subject of very rich to
subject that we do cover in some of our
work that we do at Stanford and I may
allude to it at the end but I want to
now switch gears to a second topic that
has to do with the role of the
intrapreneur and the entrepreneur to
know how to lead to know when to lead
and when to manage so as we know in
small companies in particular when we
are resource constraints we wear many
hats and the leader is very often asked
to also be a manager and long-term
projects as many of you who are
listening to this know we have to do
many things and some of them require
leadership some require management and
to be effective we have to understand
the difference between managing and
leading and this is a topic that I knew
subconsciously over the decades but I
really never started looking at it more
specifically and yet it's a very simple
concept but when you look at it more
specifically I think you understand some
of the dynamics and I'm going to quickly
go through some of the some of the
different aspects of leadership versus
management and I realize we are running
short of time so let me go rather
quickly through this I'm going to just
touch on some of the key elements of the
differentiate leadership and management
a leader points a manager plans a leader
aligns a manager organizes a leader
inspires a manager problem solves a
leader produces change a manager
produces predictability these are very
different strengths and very different
inclinations so let's just look at this
briefly a leader points basically as we
know the leader is chartered with
defining a vision and direction of
manager plans establishes tasks budgets
program
a leader Alliance we know that a leader
it has to be a good articulator
that engages the team in the direction
they want to go whereas a manager is
chartered with identifying skills and
staff a leader inspires motivates
creates the culture a manager problem
solves foresees and addresses hurdles
and finally a leader produces change
expands our horizons of the possible and
the manager assures that we can reach
them it's a very rich topic and I highly
recommend that you go to this particular
Harvard Business Review report please
jot it down it's called what leaders
really do and it captures the the
elements of this particular important
subject so let's touch briefly now on
some of the things that we can do to
both be able to do the leadership and
the management tasks and at the same
time not lose sight of our
responsibility to absorb uncertainty I
can have the next slide please
it comes back to the ability to
understand yourself as a leader both in
terms of your inner characteristics your
outer characteristics and your core
characteristics and there is a lot of
richness inside these topics they define
the various stages in effect as you
engage a team to create a new new
venture or a new business the inner
characteristics Dom are key in the risk
capacity the outer characteristics in
the persuasion capacity and the core
characteristics in the execution
capacity the things to keep in mind as
we go into this topic is it's very
important to know your own propensity in
addition it's important to sense when
it's time to lead and when it's time to
manage and to act and both of them in a
consistent way that is genuine and
within
some obvious things if you need
management bolstering you can get good
training and even after 30 years of
having been a leader and a CEO I still
find that I can learn more and how to
become a better manager if you need
leadership sharpening something that has
been extremely effective in my life and
I highly recommend it and many have this
experience is to get a good executive
coach or mentor which creates a good
secondary and a clear vantage point and
finally and perhaps most difficult when
building a team and when hiring we need
to appreciate good managers but we need
to make sure we don't confuse good
management with good leadership and I
won't bore you with the details but I
have many situations failures where in
fact I have missed this and and I've not
been very happy with the consequences so
the bottom line is that we need to be
very thoughtful about this and I want to
close with a leadership alert which is
in particular important for the
entrepreneurial leader and that is to be
careful with a syndrome that I can do it
faster and quicker myself and on that
note I turn it over to Michelle
thank you very much Ricardo I appreciate
you sharing that that insight with us
and now I'd like to very quickly share
some information about the hosts of this
webinar session the molecular
engineering of energy technologies or as
you've heard us affectionately refer to
it as the meet certificate program they
have hosted this session and I'd like to
bring Professor shocks Frye back into
the discussion
and just ask a couple of questions to
learn a little bit more about this Eric
if you can help us understand what was
the inspiration for creating this new
certificate program within the chemical
engineering department so I touched upon
a little bit before we have you know
more than half of our undergraduates and
a large fraction of our graduate
students who want to be educated in
energy research modern energy research
from our point of view the critical
old transformations that are going on in
developing new energy technologies are
all molecular nanoscale technologies and
then we realized that that education was
very very valuable for other people that
are already in the field so we decided
to bring together a subset of us who
were particularly interested in energy
education broadly speaking to talk about
molecular transformations and to
approach the problem from all different
facets from the bio facet from the
catalytic facet from the energy
absorption facet from all different
molecular facets and we put together a
number of what I think are great and and
mostly brand-new courses just out of the
enthusiasm of our faculty to to spread
the word and why is this topic so
important right now and so relevant to
industry right well all all relevant
alternative energy technologies
essentially to fill the energy demand I
know it's the first question today and
we're going to get to that is is what is
going to keep the focus on alternative
energy part of the thing that's going to
keep the focus on alternative energy is
just simply demand even if even if we
even if we get all the unconventional
oil out of the ground our demand is
going to outstrip our fossil fuels so so
there's going to be a focus on energy
for the foreseeable future and there is
a real feeling now that there's an
understanding of the environmental
concerns and so though we feel like and
all we feel like all technological
achievements in this area breakthroughs
if you will are going to be at the
molecular level going forward so that's
why it's very important right excellent
well thank you very much general for
participating in the presentation today
and sharing your research with our
audience ok so the first question that
we received today is with the windfall
opportunities right now in the US and
the production of unconventional oil and
gas
how will the u.s. maintain focus on the
basic research in renewable energy
sources and I'm going to go ahead and
turn it over to any of our speakers that
would care to answer this question well
thank you Michelle so that's a really
good question and especially with the
shale gas which is a very
hot topic right now so it's an
interesting history with modern history
I'll call it of this convention of
unconventional shale gas if you'd have
somebody five years ago then the fossil
resources were looking pretty bleak if
you have somebody two years ago it would
have seen that there's so much natural
gas that we're good for the next 200
years and but now the the temperament
has changed once again and so it's not
so clear anymore that we're going to
have hundreds of years worth of natural
gas but we do we will probably have on
the order of a couple of decades worth
of natural gas which i think is good
news for all of us in siddur it to be a
stopgap solution it is something that is
done already it's a technology we
already have at scale and therefore we
can use natural gas is what it's going
to do is buy us some time to allow
renewables to get to where they need to
be to ultimately be the long-term
solution so from everybody that I've
talked to at the US Department of Energy
and this includes Secretary Steven Chu
who I met personally a few months ago
and asked them this very question it's
not clear that the natural gas is going
to continue long enough for us to be
able to rely on that we need to get
renewables onto the market and that is
going to take a while it will take
decades even if we had viable solutions
here today it would take decades to roll
these technologies out at the terawatt
level which is where they need to be to
ultimately replace fossil fuels so this
unconventional oil and gas again is
pretty much buying US time is the is the
bottom line thanks Tom let me add one
more thing to that the shale oil there
are lots of technological challenges
with getting shale oil as well so in the
chemical engineering department there's
a whole separate research climate and
research experience with shale oil and
there's a lot of money coming in from -
to the chemical engineering department
to do to shale oil research so there'll
be there are real technological
challenges there to get quote-unquote
all of that oil out of the ground so I
think that will if you will compete in
the short term with the technological
challenges for renewable energy sources
as well just a final thing here I think
the key issue and I've been I've been
the biomass electricity business for a
number of years the key issue is really
the cost and I think that goes right
back to the technology and I think what
we need to do as scientists and
technologies is to find those
breakthroughs that take us one or two
orders of magnitude past the point where
we are now because if that happens we
start moving away from needing
government subsidy and we start being
competitive and and I think if we do
that then there are a lot of
opportunities for for new businesses
thank you very much the next question
that we have is is the 20% renewable a
max that the current grid can handle and
what is the reason for the 20%
requirement from many states ok I'd be
happy to address that too so about the
20% requirement for many states that's
definitely a policy question and
actually I don't know what fed in for
the policymakers deciding on the 20%
they could have actually been talking
with technical folks I would hope and
and realize that the max is 20% at least
with the current grid and the but the
the 20% is not for all grids it's
actually for a very smartly designed
grid and so actually a lot of grids in
the United States we have an aging
electricity grid can't even support the
20% that's stated so the reason for that
is again if you're going to be
incorporating these renewables with
intermittent resources you need to be
shuffling energy around all over the
place at a moment's notice if the wind
starts dying down or if a cloud passes
overhead and starts blocking the Sun and
so this is what's giving the
technological reason for the 20% it
could potentially be pushed higher but
there's going to be a fundamental limit
because if it were a hundred percent at
the limit of a hundred percent coming
from intermittent renewables you can
imagine you're once the Sun Goes Down
you're not going to get any power out of
that so so 20% it's still a ballpark
number it could be pushed a little bit
higher up depending on how smart you're
willing to engineer a brand-spanking-new
grid if you're going to like design a
brand new city with a brand new grid but
that 20% number is pretty much a maximum
so we need good forms of energy storage
however that might be
thank you the next question is the Sun
storms affect the magnetic field of the
earth continuously is there a way to
harness this I don't know first I'll go
ahead and answer this I would say that
there are many many many ways to harness
energy and and I am sure that there is a
way to harness it
I am also sure that right now there
would not be a cost-effective way to do
it and that's really the question could
there ever be a cost-effective way to do
it and so I'd like to say that in
chemical engineering that's one of the
advantages of coming from this field you
know one thing that we do really well
and we teach all the time is scalability
and how to scale up processes to really
large scale and so you know the way I
would look at a question like this is I
would say well let's do a technical
economic design of basically let's look
at a technology let's pretend that that
technology actually works in terms of
harnessing this energy source and then
let's build a plant around it that would
actually provide electricity
continuously based on that phenomenon
and so you can do all the costing or you
know a lot of the costing without having
the technology in hand yet and I think
that's a really nice way to steer us
until what are the most viable options
because we can at least get a baseline
price of what it might look like if one
we're able to develop the technology to
be as efficient as one would hope it to
be thanks for taking that one's on
another question Ken salt or sodium be
used to store the energy absolutely
but of course so you design about
chemical conversions so this is kind of
a unidirectional conversion where if you
had a sodium metal for instance and you
know just to make things really simple
you throw it in water it oxidizes like
crazy it releases tons of energy but
then you've done it ones one shot you've
got to get it back into a metallic
sodium state so how are you going to do
that you're going to need energy somehow
and so it's a different way of looking
at the problem can it be done
technologically absolutely but it's
probably not going to be as reversible
because really again you think of it as
an energy in and energy out how
effective are you at putting as little
energy in as possible to reduce it and
and any scheme that I have seen to this
to date that uses this type of concept
basically requires too much of an energy
so it doesn't look like a cost-effective
solution idea to see a cost-effective
solution come out there but I don't want
to discourage anyone from thinking about
it because there could very well be some
some way of taking advantage of that
type of conversion excellent and another
question is does spectroscopy play a
role here laughter because I teach the
class so Tammy 3:45 is is spectroscopy
molecular spectroscopy and it absolutely
provides a major role because
spectroscopy is that is our eyes and
ears when it comes to molecules we
cannot we cannot see atoms we cannot see
the molecules but we can shine light on
the molecules we can we can throw
electrons at the molecules and we can
see how they respond so it's basically
our molecular eyes and ears so if you
ever want to be effective at developing
a technology that can do conversions
between molecules you need to see how
they're behaving spectroscopy is how we
see how they behave not to mention the
materials themselves and how they
interact with those molecules so
spectroscopy is fun as a fundamental
basic science that is a part of any
energy technology that ever gets ruled
out yeah let me let me follow up a
little bit on that more than a decade
ago the chemical engineering department
decided to have spectroscopy as
essentially a key feature in our
curriculum because we realized that most
of the engineering in the next few
decades and going forward was going to
be molecular and that it was going to be
critical for students to understand
molecular probes including spectroscopy
so we now have tom's course as a staple
of our curriculum and have for more than
a decade excellent we do have one one
additional question what is the dollar
cost and energy cost of manufacturing
the nano porous catalyst so the answer
to that question is it's expensive right
now and and that's because we're we're
making we're developing these materials
in our laboratory and so since there
this is a research grade activity you
know right now we're not thinking about
minimizing the cost at this point we're
trying to make the best material that we
can and then once we make it as long as
we know that it comes from
earth-abundant materials then we can
envision a pathway to making a scalable
route to that type of a material so the
answer is x t equals zero as in right
now it's not a cheap way to do it but it
can absolutely be made inexpensively I
have note there is no doubt about that
because molybdenum and sulfur are two of
the cheapest most abundant elements on
the face of the earth and it can scale
to the terawatt level no problem
excellent thank you very much and so
with that I am going to thank you for
joining us today for our presentation